how did you start over in Atlanta so I
was working an I.T job as a network
engineer and I was sitting there
and this was right before covet so this
was like 2019.
uh that this happened and I was looking
at the landscape mind you at this point
I I kind of quit Hollywood for a while I
wasn't audition and wasn't doing
anything and I was looking at the
landscape and I still did not see what I
wanted to see what my goal was when I
went out there I didn't see it and just
for some insight what the goal was
um if I break it down further than like
the Asian Will Smith it was really
seeing a leading Asian guy
in a non-asian role so what that means
is
if you see someone like myself
but it there is no kung fu there is no
okay this is about an Asian family in
Malaysia there's nothing it's just like
hey that guy
uh just so happens to be Asian there is
no Asian story we don't own a liquor
store there's no laundromat there's no
Kung Fu there's no sidekick it's just oh
he's the love interest and he just so
happens to be Asian
when you create stories like that it
becomes powerful because now it's it's
just normal it's just normal right
you're not you're not highlighting the
fact that this person's Asian they're
just
a human being playing a role
so because I didn't witness that enough
right and you have your hits right you
have your shangshi Marvel film fantastic
but the title is shangshi
it's a martial arts film
that takes place
where there's a lot of Asians then you
have something else like uh crazy Rich
Asians the title is Asians
dealing with an Asian family so of
course you're going to cast Asians now
mind you these films are fantastic films
but in order to separate that Gap
really for all ethnicities
you have to play regular roles right and
you can't
Force right and a lot of times today we
see forced you can't force something
that's already established
and what I mean by that is
if this franchise has a history
and this character and a fan base along
with that history
and this character like let's say Iron
Man right Robert Downey Jr that's
everyone's Iron Man Iron Man Has looked
like Iron Man
since the beginning right
if you now put
uh
another racist Iron Man
it's not going to work
because of the history associated with
that character
you have to create new
characters you have to create new
stories as whatever that race is or
whatever you want to be
that's a lot easier to digest from a fan
base because it's new
than it is to
swap somebody out because it's trending
today because now you're alienating
the 50 60 years of fans that have
purchased those comic books that have
read those stories that have fallen in
love with these characters for instance
I'm a big anime guy
I love Dragon Ball Z if I ever get the
opportunity to direct or be a part of
any Dragon Ball Z live action film I
swear I would do it justice
but we all know as anime fans
what these characters look like right
and here is where it's it's that fine
line so because we all know we've been
with these characters for people that
are my age we've been with these
characters for
25 years
this is what we we like love and we are
into
if you change that
or
or you gender swap it or anything
for us fans who are Die Hard who will go
watch anything related to that you've
now alienated us
for for whatever reason now if you want
to race swap it gender swap it or
anything like that create a new story
create a new comic create new characters
create new story lines create a new
world right that's the beauty of film
you can create anything and put anybody
in any role
so with my films when I write
they're just new story lines and a lot
of times I put myself in the leading
role because my goal is to break that
barrier and the way I do that is
they have like if you think of something
like a like four Amigos or like my a
film we just wrapped it where it's in
post now it's called pizza boy brick
it has nothing to do with race I just so
happen to be an Asian guy in the film
but because it has nothing to do with
race you don't see that
it's just like oh he's just playing this
character that's how you break the wall
down not by forcing it like oh okay hey
guys today we're gonna put an Asian guy
in this role
like if you put
me as black panther that's not gonna
work no one's gonna look at that and say
okay yes yes we want no nobody wants it
I don't even want that that doesn't work
so I think that's where creating your
own story and originality is extremely
powerful and if you want to see change
in the Dynamics of Hollywood in American
Cinema then you as the writer as the
filmmaker you have to be that change you
have to create that change if you're
Indian Asian black like it doesn't
matter you have to write the story from
your perspective because you can't
expect somebody that's not your race to
write you as that leading guy because
they don't know your perspective they
know their perspective so if you want to
create change and you want to be a part
of change and you're sitting there and
you're like oh why haven't they done
that don't make excuses go create the
change because even if I break one layer
in my career the next person will come
and break two layers and then before you
know it there's a trail
what about everything everywhere all at
once
how is that for a beautiful film
beautiful storyline in terms of the
stereotypes
there's so with something like that
there is the exception right
people are going to create what they
know and what they love
right
so
the creators of that they made the low
John video
I forget what the music video was but it
had like an Asian dude that was dancing
crazy and it was breaking through the
floors in the wall and like their style
is very very creative
that's fine it's a it's fine to make
time skip in martial arts action that's
fine because that's what we've seen
as far as what we're used to from let's
say someone that's Asian
but if you want to continue to keep
pushing that boundary then we have to be
the love interest we have to be uh the
guy that saves the day
right we have to do these things and not
have it tied to our lineage
so if you think of something like
let's say
um
it wouldn't work but like let's say
House of dragons
right if the King was an Asian guy
but it had nothing to do
with him protecting an Asian
state or or property or you know land
and the way he got that power was he
killed the king
that's powerful
because it has nothing to do with him
being Asian he just so happens to be the
guy that killed the king and now he's
the king and everyone fears him so
they're not gonna
approach him right
that's where the little minute changes
happen
and and to your point it really takes
creators
of different ethnic groups to create
because only you can create from your
voice your experience
and your perspective no one else can do
that for you
how do you think it is for people to say
well yeah there's there's all sorts of
you know whatever there's rrr there's um
you know the Shahs of Sunset there's
crazy Rich Asians there's all these
these shows out there but it it's it's
only like within one world yes so it
kind of just like exists but but it's
not there's no diversity it's just all
one of each kind and and here's the
thing America is like the Melting Pot of
the world right seeing every race is
normal whether you're uh at the grocery
store grabbing a bite to eat we all
blend we're all a bunch of everything
right
so
in order for
anyone to see
anything that represents them on screen
they have to create it you can't expect
someone else to create
your story your pain
if they're not like you it just it they
can't because their lens is different
right
so when you mention
Triple R
fantastic film by the way I loved it
yeah
um
but that's in all encompassing
film
with its own ethnicity Associated to
that film
and that's fine because you're going to
always have those
but that's not an American film
when you're talking about American
Cinema and you hear in the news you hear
from all these creatives like oh this
person you know doesn't like this or
this person hates this or why can't this
person be this
how about all the noise stop and how
about action take over and how about
people start writing start creating
start filming start casting start
producing instead of talking talking for
someone else to go do that
if you're constantly talking for someone
else to do it
then it's going to take a lot longer for
it to ever get done if it ever gets done
so we've seen
strides I would say nowadays it's kind
of like a lot of times it's forced
that's why it doesn't work because it's
forced nothing forced works even when
your parents say hey go do the dishes
right now like you reluctantly go to do
them dishes compared to
you know hey get these dishes done
I'm going to make sure that you know
whatever it is that you're trying to
accomplish the iPod or iPad or whatever
that you wanted you do these dishes
enough time without me having to tell
you I'm going to make sure I get that
for you okay cool now not that you have
to come to some kind of agreement with
your kid but
it's a lot easier than having to force
them to go do something because now they
don't want to do it
so it sounds like if something
is too much within its stereotype then
it's it feels like it's too patronizing
maybe yes because now you're only seeing
blue
when in fact we live in a rainbow right
when you see too much of one color
that's that's what it is right it's it's
like okay yeah that makes sense that's
that kind of film
but if you're trying to blend everything
then
it's important for those new stories to
flourish those new filmmakers to direct
and create and to cast you know
for those roles because if not then why
would it change if the business has been
successful for a hundred years and it's
been financially
um
uh in the positive then why would they
change that why would they go and take a
risk if you think about it right even
big actors that are established they
have to go screen test
sometimes they have to audition right
if they have to do that and they are
proven what makes you think that they're
going to go with an unknown
different ethnic group
for this row and take a risk on you and
invest 50 to 100 million dollars for you
to go and hopefully bring a return
that's not going to happen or if it is
it's super rare but if you go create
your own story and you go and make that
film and it becomes successful now
there's a track record
for you to level up
and have the opportunity
to expand that Vision in that voice
you know how there's the Bechtel test
the test certain things about how women
are portrayed or or how they're seen
through the lens do you do that with
your films where it's like okay I don't
know if I want to do an ethnic
stereotype I know this person checks
this box but I don't want them to fit
that role so I don't check any boxes
um
my films are super
diverse but it's not on purpose
um I get the best people really energy
wise and they all are very talented
but I get people that I like and when we
collaborate on a project
there is no okay I'm putting this person
in this role because they're this that
doesn't exist on any of my projects and
when we film I give everyone the
creative freedom to do whatever they
want I don't care what they say I don't
care how they say it I don't care how
they play it just know that if in this
scene it's important to mention a glass
of water
right because somewhere else later in
the film a glass of water something
happens with that glass of water then
okay hey I don't I don't care how you
get here just say something about the
glass of water
everyone has the freedom to play it
however they want so there is no
stereotype because you're playing it
however you see it
um and I think that's important
so when I cast outside of great energy
um
I personally just don't see
really anything outside of that's
another human being so any role in any
film movie that I make anybody can play
it
anybody can play any role and it's
finest sometimes on any films you'll
Shuffle like hey you know what last
minute like okay look look you go here
you go okay cool okay great and that's
kind of what's worked for me